[Rapmusik]
MURAT: Herzlich willkommen zu unserem Podcast Nr. 49, Eko.
EKO: Das sind ja schon voll die Hip Hop-Vibes hier.
Woher kommt denn diese Musik, lieber Murat?
MURAT: Das ist ein bisschen was anderes.
Wir sind jetzt beim Sturmwaffel in Köln
und er hat ein Video-Podcast-Studio,
D.h., das ist auch einer der einzigen Video-Podcasts,
die wir jemals ausstrahlen, auch jetzt auf YouTube.
weil ich es auch einfach cool fand.
Er hat mir die ganze Technik gezeigt.
Das Schöne ist…
Ich habe dich jetzt gerade auch gar nicht richtig angekündigt.
Vor mir steht Eko Fresh.
EKO: Vor mir steht Murat aus Waghäusel.
MURAT: Aus Waghäusel.
EKO: Aus Waghäusel.
Ich habe dich ja unter „Murat Waghäusel",
weil ich so viele Murats habe.
Sorry, dass ich das sage…
Ich hab dich unter „Murat Waghäusel" in meinem Handy.
MURAT: Es ist was Kulturelles,
und zwar habe ich die Leute, die ich in meinem Handy gespeichert habe…
Guck mal z.B. …
Eko kann ich mir merken, weißt du.
Aber wenn du jetzt z.B. „Ekrem" …
Du heißt ja wirklich Ekrem.
Wenn ich dich da als „Ekrem" speichern will,
würde ich sagen „Ekrem Rapper".
Weil ich ihnen auch einen „Ekrem Maler"
Und es ist immer so…
In der Türkei ist echt immer so:
Man baut immer die Berufsbezeichnung als Brücke ein,
damit du nachher weißt, wer es ist,
weil alle gleich heißen,
EKO: Das stimmt.
Bei der türkischen Nationalmannschaft steht doch immer der Vorname.
Das ist ja kulturell nochmal anders,
wie man sich das anscheinend merkt.
MURAT: Ja.
Auf jeden Fall schön, dass du heute dabei bist.
Wie gesagt, in einem anderen Raum kocht gerade die Sally mit dem Sturmi.
Wir haben uns gedacht:
Komm, lass uns mal 'nen coolen Podcast machen.
Wie gesagt, Nr. 49.
Und für die Leute, die noch nie ein Podcast von uns angehört haben:
Den gibt's bei Spotify, bei Deezer, bei Audio Now.
Der ist kostenlos, könnt euch anhören.
Der ist eigentlich nur, ehm…
Man sagt nicht visuell, sondern…
EKO: Audio.
MURAT: Nur Audio, genau.
Und jetzt haben wir mal einen visuellen Podcast.
Mit einem Typ, würde ich sagen - Eko Fresh.
Ein Typ, mit dem ich von der Musik her aufgewachsen bin, muss ich sagen.
Ich weiß, dass du dich dann immer ein bisschen älter fühlst.
Darüber haben wir schon mal gesprochen.
Das Lustige ist, dass ich zwei Jahre älter bin als du,
aber ich sage, ich bin mit dir aufgewachsen.
Seitdem du 16 bist,
bist du eigentlich schon in der Öffentlichkeit, richtig?
EKO: Ja, richtig.
Auch schon in so einer Form, dass es eigentlich gar kein Zurück mehr gab.
Also danke zunächst, dass ich hier sein darf
und die Gelegenheit hier ergreifen durfte,
während die anderen am Kochen sind.
Hier in Sturmis Studio mal mit dir ein Podcast zu machen.
Das ist mir eine große Ehre in eurer Podcast-Reihe dabei zu sein.
Es ist tatsächlich richtig so.
Das war das Erste, wonach ich in meinem Leben gefragt habe.
Ich sage immer „das Universum gefragt habe".
Und es hat direkt auf so einer großen Bühne geklappt,
dass es eigentlich schon kein Zurück mehr gab.
Und ich war eigentlich ein Schüler.
Wir unterhalten uns ja auch manchmal zwischendurch.
Ich war so jung, dass…
Also wenn ich jetzt jemand so Junges sehen würde,
dem würde ich, glaub ich, keine 100 € anvertrauen,
um irgendwie zum Lidl zu gehen und für mich was zu holen.
Ich würde immer denken, der macht bestimmt irgendwas falsch.
Ja, also so jung war ich.
MURAT: Und jemand, der dich nicht kennt…
Man sagt ja immer,
bei Rappern redet man von Gangsta-Rappern;
Leute, die dann irgendwelche Mütter beleidigen,
Frauen in ihren Texten erniedrigen oder irgendwas schreiben.
Du warst nie dieser Gangsta-Rapper, richtig?
Oder sehe ich das falsch?
Also deine Musik höre ich mir an und habe gute Laune.
Ich werde nicht wütend, möchte dann auch nicht aufmüpfig sein.
Ich bin einfach cool.
Natürlich deine krassesten Hits:
z.B. Quotentürke, Orientexpress, Köln-Kalk.
Sozialkritisch [Eko stimmt zu],
aber immer noch…
EKO: selbstironisch
MURAT: Ja, selbstironisch, aber immer noch Dinge, wo ich jetzt sagen würde.
Wenn das jetzt meine Tochter anhören würde,
die jetzt zehn Jahre alte ist,
Würde ich sagen: Hey, die Texte sind cool.
Dafür muss sie sich nicht schämen.
Damit hat sich ja Rap auch ein bisschen verändert.
Früher war ja Rap auch ein bisschen lustig,
ein bisschen auf die Schippe nehmen, auch sozialkritisch.
Heute ist es oftmals beleidigend und erniedrigend,
muss ich ehrlich sagen.
EKO: Du hast völlig recht. Ich bin auch nicht perfekt, muss ich sagen.
Ich bin auch durch Phasen in meinem Leben gegangen,
aber es war nie das, was mich ausgemacht hat.
Hast du völlig recht. Du hast völlig recht.
Es gibt Texte, auf die stolzer bin als auf andere.
Das ist völlig klar.
Du musst dir vorstellen:
Seitdem du 16 bist,
hast du so ein Mikrofon vor dem Gesicht
und hast jede Idee, die du jemals gedacht hast, aufgenommen.
Das ist, wenn du dann 37 bist, klar,
dass du nicht alles gleich findest.
Die meisten Leute, sage ich immer,
mögen nicht mal ihre Fotos sehen, wo sie 16 Jahre alt waren.
MURAT: So geht es mir z.B. [Beide lachen]
EKO: Davon gibt's ziemlich viel Material.
D.h. aber, ich habe meine Linie gefunden und ich steh auch zu der.
Z.B. hab ich ein, zwei Mixtapes, die ich nicht mehr so mag,
weil ich nicht dahinter stehe.
Die habe ich auf den Plattformen unzugänglich gemacht.
D.h., so ähnlich wie wie bei Netflix oder bei den heutigen Anbietern,
Die sagen: Okay, es gab kulturelle Unterschiede mit der Zeit
und wir Menschen sind in einem Entwicklungs- und Entstehungsprozess.
Deswegen können wir nicht mehr hinter der und der Szene stehen.
Und dann steht am Anfang, es wurde rausgeschnitten oder sonst etwas.
Sowas Ähnliches gibt's bei mir auch,
aber im Prinzip hast du völlig recht.
Das ist nie das, was für mich ausgemacht hat
und es stand bei mir nie auf der Agenda.
Ich habe nie mit dem Schockelement gespielt.
Das war nicht mein Ding.
Es gibt ja verschiedene Arten von Rap.
Ich will es jetzt nicht zu sehr ausführen,
Aber es gibt ja auch Will Smith, der auch ein Rapper ist.
MURAT: Aber es ist auch das…
Das ist auch lustig. [Eko stimmt zu]
EKO: Und dann gibt's aber auch 50 Cent.
Das ist voll der Ghetto Dude.
Also es gibt verschiedene Arten von Rap,
so wie es verschiedene Arten von Filmen gibt.
MURAT: Aber ich finde es halt krass.
Guck mal, du hast mit 16 Jahren angefangen,
dass man sich für seine…
Wenn man mit 16 Jahren Dinge macht und heut drüber nachdenkt,
denkt man:
Okay, war vielleicht nicht immer so cool oder wie auch immer.
Das Glück von der Sally ist, glaube ich:
Sie hat so richtig mit YouTube mit 25 Jahren angefangen, glaube ich.
Da ist man schon weiter und wir waren ja schon verheiratet,
hatten ja schon unser 1. Kind.
D.h., wir haben, muss ich dir ganz, ganz ehrlich sagen…
Wenn ich jetzt überlege,
sind ja auch schon ein paar Jährchen bei der Sally.
Ich glaube… Wie viele Jahre sind es jetzt?
2011 hat sie angefangen, genau vor zehn Jahren.
Wir haben noch nie ein Video gelöscht.
Also es gab keine Videos von Anfang an, weil du immer was gemacht hast,
wo du sagst: Da stehe ich auch noch nach Jahren dahinter.
Ich meine,
klar, Koch-Content und DIY-Content ist etwas anderes als jetzt Musik.
Wie du es gerade gesagt hast:
Man hat manchmal Situationen, wo man was loswerden möchte.
War zu dieser Situation, zu dieser Zeit richtig,
aber heute nicht mehr.
Wie gesagt…
Wie würdest du deine Musik heute bezeichnen?
EKO: Wie du gesagt hast:
Ich glaube, dass die Sozialkritik eine ganz große Rolle spielt.
Aber auch die Leichtigkeit.
Ich glaube, dass wir in schweren Zeiten leben
und dass die Leute es schon schwer genug haben.
Ich versuche z.B. mit der aktuellen Platte irgendwie
eher ein bisschen mit der Leichtigkeit
dazu beizutragen und zu unterhalten.
Also der Unterhaltungswert soll jetzt auch nicht
in den Hintergrund geraten,
nur weil ich auch manchmal wichtige Sachen ansprechen möchte.
Also ich glaube, dass die Leute mittlerweile mich kennen,
sich dran gewöhnt haben.
Und es gibt, glaube ich, ganz wenige Leute,
die über all die Jahre da sind.
Ob sie mal ein bisschen mehr, ein bisschen weniger Erfolg haben,
aber sie sind immer da.
Ich vergleiche das immer mit einem Fußballer,
auch wenn die z.B. nicht mehr aktiv sind.
Die gehen dann.
Aber es gibt so ein paar, auf die sich alle einigen,
die dann später Moderator werden oder Trainer oder… weißt du?
Damit vergleiche ich das und ich bin froh, einer von denen zu sein,
die das irgendwie 20 Jahre
- dieses Jahr im Dezember werden es 20 Jahre.
MURAT: Krass!
20 Jahre sozusagen, wie auf der Bühne gewesen.
EKO: Am 10. Dezember 2001 kam meine erste CD raus.
MURAT: Wir haben uns immer mit einem Kumpel zusammen…
- ich habe einen Kumpel, der Saban heißt -
deine Videos angeschaut.
Wir sagten damals: Alter, der Typ ist so durchgeknallt. [Eko lacht]
Wir fanden dich so lustig.
Weißt du? Damals sahst du auch so lustig aus.
Du warst so ein bisschen schmächtig, sah es aus der Lucky Luke,
aber hast Sachen rausgehauen, wo wir gesagt haben:
Ja, richtig cool.
Und was uns beide natürlich auch verbindet, ist das Kulturelle.
D.h., die türkische Herkunft, den Migrationshintergrund,
hier aufgewachsen zu sein, in den deutschen Medien zu sein.
Das ist immer eine schwierige Geschichte,
weil in dir 2 Herzen schlagen.
Du hast eigentlich 2 verschiedene Publika:
also einmal die türkische und einmal die deutsche Community.
Das ist saumäßig schwer, diesen Seiltanz zu schaffen,
von beiden geliebt zu werden.
Also ich würde sagen, meine Frau hat es hinbekommen,
dass die deutsche Community sagt:
Hey, Sally ist unser Mädchen.
Und die türkische Community sagt:
Nein, es ist unser Mädchen. Weißt du, was ich meine?
Also es ist so ein Battle zwischen den beiden.
Wir sind für beide da.
Es ist aber wirklich ein Tanz auf dem heißen Feuer,
jemanden nicht zu enttäuschen.
Da gibt es eine ganz, ganz krasse Situation.
Über die haben wir geredet; die möchte ich gerade mal aufgreifen.
EKO: Moment, ich wollte nur mal…
Du hast gerade mein Leben erklärt.
Wir können auch an der Stelle aufhören. [Beide lachen]
Genau das ist es.
MURAT: Du hast wirklich diesen Kampf. [Eko stimmt zu]
Den führe ich auch jeden Tag
und wir beide erleben Rassismus jeden Tag.
EKO: Ich glaube, die Sally ist einfach hübscher
und schlauer als wir. [Murat stimmt zu]
Deswegen mag sie auch jeder. [Murat lacht]
MURAT: Aber wir sind wenigstens ehrlich, müssen wir ehrlich sagen.
EKO: Aber du hast völlig recht.
Okay, ich hab dich unterbrochen.
MURAT: Gar kein Thema! Also wir erleben beide…
oder wenn ich jetzt beide sage.
Wir beide erleben Rassismus von beiden Seiten.
Es ist wirklich krass.
Wir sind für die türkische Community deutsch.
Für die deutsche Community sind wir türkisch.
Wir fühlen uns zu beiden Communities hingezogen
und lieben es auch mit den Vorurteilen zu spielen,
auch Vorurteile zu widerlegen.
D.h., wir sind nicht mehr der Türke,
der jetzt auf einer Baustelle arbeitet,
der Türke, der jetzt da arbeitet.
Wir sind auch Menschen, die es zu etwas gebracht haben,
wo man drauf stolz sein kann.
Wir sind stolz auf Deutschland, aber auch auf die Türkei.
Wir haben gerade ein Riesenthema, auch in Deutschland.
Das ist ein sehr, sehr trauriges Thema.
Es war die Flutkatastrophe z.B. - da warst du ja auch dort.
Ich habe ja auch die Bilder von dir gesehen, wo du geholfen hast,
mit dem Onur zusammen, richtig? [Eko bejaht]
EKO: Genau, Onur Koç.
MURAT: Genau, Onur Koç. Liebe Grüße gehen an Onur raus.
Wo du mit deiner Frau auch in Ahrweiler warst, richtig?
Und hast dann geholfen,
Nachdem du mitbekommen hast,
dass eine Flutkatastrophe passiert ist, bist runtergefahren.
Ich habe gesehen,
wie du mit deiner Frau zusammen tagelang geholfen hast.
Bei uns war die Flutkatastrophe auch ein Thema.
Wir haben das dann… Es war…
Ich muss ganz kurz erklären, wie es war.
Das war morgens bei uns.
Wir haben ganz normal gedreht.
Alles super, tolle Laune.
Dann kam dann von Zuschauern.
Hey Murat, hast du es nicht gesehen?
Die Flutkatastrophe in NRW und in Rheinland-Pfalz…
Bitte macht was.
Wir vertrauen euch
und wir wissen nicht, wo wir helfen und wem wir spenden sollen.
Dann habe ich meine Frau dazu aufgerufen und habe gesagt:
Schatz, komm, hör mal zu!
Wir müssen uns sofort eine Kamera holen
und sofort über die Flutkatastrophe reden.
Wir müssen den Menschen helfen.
Dann ging es darum, mit unserer Stiftung zu helfen.
Mit unser Stiftung konnten wir nicht helfen,
weil in der Satzung steht:
Wir dürfen nur Kindern helfen - in Erziehung und in Familien.
Dann haben wir einen Spendenaufruf gemacht
- das ging an Aktion Deutschland -
und haben dann, nach ungefähr einer Woche, fast eine halbe Million…
Halbe Million?!
… gesammelt.
EKO: Hast du Bomben-Sound hier?
Kannst du eine Bombe platzen lassen?
Nein, Spaß beiseite.
Alter Schwede! Alter Schwede! Unglaublich!
Wozu… ? Was für eine Nächstenliebe!
Wozu die Community fähig ist!
MURAT: Wir haben auch ganz, ganz tolle Zuschauer, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Also 80 % unserer Zuschauer sind weiblich; das wissen wir.
80 % sind zwischen 18-54 Jahren, also etwas älter,
was eigentlich bei YouTube sehr, sehr selten ist.
Und auch Menschen jeglicher Herkunft.
Da haben dann Türken und Italiener gespendet.
Es war einfach sowas Wundervolles.
Alle haben mitgeholfen.
Wir tun immer noch was.
Bei den Spenden gibt's natürlich immer wieder Störgeräusche, weißt du?
Könnt ihr nicht?
Wieso spendet ihr nicht mehr?
Ihr habt doch so viel.
Wir machen auch sehr viel, wir zeigen aber nicht alles.
Man muss auch nicht immer alles zeigen,
aber trotzdem andere zu motivieren, auch zu spenden.
Das hast du ja auch gemacht.
Und das Schlimme ist, man denkt ja immer, es ist schon schlimm
und dann wird es noch schlimmer.
Dann kam das große Feuer in der Türkei.
In der Türkei war das dann einfach so:
Dann hat uns auch unsere türkische Community angeschrieben.
Murat, jetzt habt doch bei der Flutkatastrophe geholfen.
Bitte helft doch auch bei der Feuerkatastrophe.
Und das krasse war halt auch noch,
dass das erste Feuer so richtig in Manavgat…
EKO: Da, wo ihr herkommt, richtig?
MURAT: Ja, da kommen wir her.
Also Sallys Eltern kommen ja aus Konya,
aber die haben eine Wohnung in Manavgat
und ihre ganze Familie ist in Manavgat.
D.h., es hat uns nicht nur aus den Medien betroffen,
sondern auch noch persönlich.
Wir haben auch persönliche Anrufe und Bilder bekommen.
Hey, macht euch keine Sorgen, uns geht's gut, helft uns!
Es hat einen richtig fertiggemacht,
weil es dann plötzlich…
Da hast du die Bilder im Kopf gehabt
und nicht nur die aus Instagram, Facebook und aus den Medien.
Dann haben wir wieder eine…
Wir konnten nicht anders, weißt du, Eko?
Es ist einfach so: Das gehört uns beiden.
Verstehst du, was ich meine?
Wir sind türkisch, wir sind aber auch deutsch.
Wir haben bei der Flutkatastrophe geholfen.
Dann ist es auch unsere Verpflichtung,
auch noch einmal in der Türkei zu helfen.
Eigentlich ist so eine krasse Geschichte,
weil die Leute uns als Erstes anschreiben.
Das hat mit Vertrauen zu tun.
Die vertrauen uns, dass wir den Menschen helfen,
aber das macht uns psychisch komplett fertig.
Also es macht uns richtig fertig, wenn uns Menschen anschreiben:
Hey, ich habe alles verloren, bitte helft mir!
Du kannst aber nicht allen helfen. Das ist ein Riesenproblem.
Also haben wir dann wieder eine Spendenaktion ins Leben gerufen,
jetzt auch für die für die Brandopfer in der Türkei.
Und was mich voll fertig gemacht hat, Eko:
In der Türkei war es anders.
Die Leute haben nicht nur gedacht:
Wir müssen sofort helfen, sei es mit Geld oder mit Sachspenden,
sondern in der Türkei wurde dann eher erst einmal
der Schuldige gesucht.
EKO: Da wurde es politisiert.
MURAT: Da wurde es völlig politisiert.
Die Leute schreiben dann.
Sally, wieso erwähnst nicht,
dass es ein Terroranschlag seitens der PKK war.
Sally, wieso erwähnst du nicht, dass es die Hoteliers gemacht haben,
weil sie eine Brandrodung machen möchten,
dass sie noch mehr bauen können?
Sally, der Erdoğan war schuld und was weiß ich, was…
EKO: Also es werden schon Theorien aufgestellt,
MURAT: anstatt es erst einmal um die Opfer gehen sollte.
Und auch bei Facebook war ich sowas von gekränkt.
Dann kamen natürlich wieder, auch aus Deutschland, Äußerungen wie:
Jetzt helft ihr erst einmal den Flutopfer
und dann kann man den Türken immer noch helfen.
Verstehst du, was ich meine?
Und du stehst halt immer mittendrin.
Im Endeffekt willst du nur helfen, verstehst du?
Dann kriegst du aus der türkischen Community:
Ja, da habt ihr eine halbe Million zusammengesammelt.
Warum macht ihr es nicht für die Türkei?
Dabei machen wir es ja auch, verstehst du?
Und das macht einen richtig fertig.
Es ist auch, beiden immer gerecht zu werden.
D.h., der gute Türke zu sein, aber auch der gute Deutsche zu sein.
Weißt du, und du bist immer zwischendrin
und du weißt gar nicht mehr, wo du anpacken sollst.
Das kennst du ja auch. Eko.
Du wirst ja auch voll oft angeschrieben.
Mach doch was, tu doch was!
Mir haben sogar Leute geschrieben, ich soll Helikopter schicken.
Ich habe ja so gute die Beziehung in die Politik,
weil wir schon im Bundeskanzleramt waren.
Wir sollen doch alles dafür tun,
dass Deutschland Löschflugzeuge in die Türkei schickt.
Ich denk mir dann: Hey, was erwarten die Menschen?
Verstehst du, was ich meine?
EKO: Ja, ich glaube, dass sie teilweise gar nicht mehr so weit denken,
zu sagen, dass du quasi ein normaler Mensch bist
mit einem normalen Tagesablauf,
sondern für den mit der Zeit zu einer Art Symbol geworden ist,
zu dem die sich wenden.
Dasselbe erkenne ich nämlich auch bei mir.
Ich versuche natürlich auch psychologisch
immer und immer wieder drüber nachzudenken:
In welcher Situation bin ich?
Du sagst es - hin und hergerissen.
Ein Freund von mir hat es mal so beschrieben.
Liebst du Deutschland oder die Türkei?
Das ist so, wie wenn man dich fragt:
Liebst du deine Mutter oder deinen Vater?
Super Beispiel, wirklich, super!
Du kannst ja nicht sagen: Ich liebe den oder den.
Alle haben ihre Vor- und Nachteile,
aber letztendlich liebst du beide.
Ich glaube diese Erwartungshaltung kommt einfach.
Große Menschen oder große Taten
haben natürlich auch große Erwartungen in den Leuten,
aber ich glaube, die müssen einem einfach vertrauen,
dass man seinen Wertekompass
und seine Erfahrungen in solche Situationen einfließen lässt,
vielleicht bei manchen Sachen erst abwartet
und dann so handelt oder so handelt.
Ich sage dir ein Beispiel:
Ich habe auch ganz lange überlegt, ob ich da diese Fotos teile.
Ich habe ja nicht als einziger geholfen.
Wir waren eine ganze Crew, aber ich war der einzige dort…
- also vielleicht bis auf meine Frau noch -
der irgendwie diese Reichweite besitzt.
MURAT: Der in der Öffentlichkeit steht.
EKO: Genau. Und ganz besonders hat nämlich ein Freund von mir
das alles organisiert und das ist eine riesen Organisation.
Du kannst nicht einfach irgendwo hinfahren.
Du musst erst einmal darüber nachdenken. Wir brauchen die Hilfe.
Und ohne diesen Freund
- er bzw. sein Vater hat nämlich eine Baufirma -
hätten wir es gar nicht machen können.
Er hatte die Lastwagen, er hatte die Schubkarren,
er hatte einfach die Manpower usw.
D.h., eigentlich war er es.
Ich war nur einer von vielen, die dann mit angepackt haben.
Die ganze Folge jetzt bei deinem Podcast-Anbieter.